quand il a accueilli le jugement votre
client avec soulagement il faut imaginer
quand même la scène on a vu les images
donc la plupart des téléspectateurs
connaissent c'est le jet d'une bouteille
d'eau cristalline dans un volume peu
élevé vous l'avez l'a d'ailleurs je
l'avais on peut l'apprendre non mais
c'est bon c'est canon mais elle a
disparu voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
c'est à peu près de ce format là lancer
une vingtaine de mètres quand même parce
que la personne ait dans les gradins et
c'est vrai que dimitri payet lui il est
au point de corner et je moi j'ai la
conviction absolue qui voulaient même
pas touché en fait il ya eu deux vagues
de pluie de projectiles une première
n'atteint personnes et la seconde ou là
à ce moment là il s'empare d'une
bouteille la lancent ils à une vingtaine
de mètres et il parvient à toucher et
c'est vrai c'est un hasard il a tout
fait
alors c'est certain avant de tirer ouais
oui ça a été évoqué par le point non
mais je pense que en fait il a mis la
capuche pour pouvoir lancer l'objet de
là à dire qu'il voulait atteindre
dimitri payet à la tête et vous
sincèrement il ya un fossé mais parce
qu'il a d'abord il a rien qu'on me
dimitri payet mais sincèrement il a rien
contre lui ils ignoraient qu'il y avait
eu un précédent sas a aussi beaucoup
joué dans l'esprit dans l'état
psychologique de dimitri payet on l'a
découvert en tout cas pour ma part au
tribunal c'est un bon avocat à
la bouteille d'eau
j'étais la beauté
est pris par l'effet de groupe il l'a
fait c'est une bêtise et il a été
condamné pour ça moi il ya une chose qui
m'étonne c'est que d'habitude sur les
matches surtout sur ces matches-là dont
on sait qu'ils sont tendus c'est la
rencontre des olympiques c'est les
lyonnais contre les marseillais et des
antagonismes normalement il ya des files
un stade à waimes est d'accord
maintenant il ya des filets l'algérie
sont par terre pendant la rencontre je
vous assure il les mettait messi ouais
on va prendre des airs
mais trouvez pas que ça je le prendrais
sigean problème
et surtout pas franchement faut le payer
en bouteille d'eau
non mais qui est il joué ou jouent sont
pas les noms mais pas lui reprocher non
voilà je suis sur scène je suis pas dans
un rôle parce que au final je crois
avoir un contradicteur sur ce terrain là
mais moi je défends la décision du
tribunal je veux dire c'est même pas ma
conviction c'est la justice qui est
passé hier et pour revenir à votre
question oui le client est soulagé parce
qu'il est sorti ses six mois ferme ont
été requis quand même sur six mois ferme
et une interdiction de stade de stats
pardon dont on ne peut pas se fixer à 5
ans c'est le maximum légal on met à
faire parler de tout monique et dire il
n'a pas voulu il n'a pas voulu toucher
payet la meilleure manière de ne pas
toucher payet s'est pas lancé la
bouteille non mais déjà revenir là
dessus ensuite il ya un travail qui a
été fait dans d'autres clubs notamment
au paris saint germain où aller au parc
des princes 2 dans le temps c'était une
expérience d'insécurité un jour est un
homme qui est arrivé aux dans le mur où
il a dit il ya deux catégories et les
supporters ya les délinquants votre
client est un délinquant et pour moi il
n'a plus sa place dans un stade aviva
déjà pendant cinq ans la non mais cinq
ans et pas assez vous rendez compte que
l'on puisse vous arriver alors cyril dit
vous êtes un bon avocat d'accord vous
êtes un bon embrouilleur et vous faites
passer le message quant à passer un bon
avocat oui c'est parfois souvent ce soir
c'est synonyme c'est à dire que vous
envoyez le message se rapportant un
sport qui est beaucoup regardé par les
jeunes ou minimiser l'acte en misant au
fond c'est pas grave ils voulaient pas
le toucher et pourquoi n'y avait pas de
filet donc c'est la faute de tout le
monde sauf de votre client ce que vous
faites devant la jeunesse sportive des
des gamins qui jouent au foot tous les
tous les dimanches et qui vont voir des
matchs je trouve ça scandaleux ce que
vous envoyer comme message c'est
catastrophique avec attaches trouvait
avec naulleau vous êtes collection
retenue vous êtes dans la caricature
vous êtes par la caricature permanente
non pour les caricatures avait voté
expliqué au revoir aux cimes à quel
moment j'ai dit que ce qu'il avait fait
n'était pas une infraction c'est un
délit mini hollandais aggravé vous mais
absolument pas non mais attendez toute
la nuance est de savoir si cet homme a
sa place en détention ou pas vous savez
en france comment on fixe une peine en
tout cas hélas pas sa place vitale je
voudrais pas en france je voudrais que
la loi change si vous trouvez de la
chaîne jean d'indy vous auriez choix
vous auriez voulu qu'elle pousse
sanctions vous eric naulleau exclusion à
vie de tout ce stade cet homme n'a rien
à faire dans un stade un existe un stade
qu'elle est mais qu'est ce qui se passe
dans la tête de cet homme qui prend une
petite ou d'un fou dit voilà un joueur
de l'équipe adverse je vais me lancer
une bouteille annexe et des coquins ce
qui se passe avec vous après sahin
supporters ça arrive et ça un voyou un
délinquant donc des et moi je pense que
là les incidents se multiplient depuis
quelques temps il y avait un message à
faire passer moi j'aurais souhaité que y
ait de la prison ferme pour votre client
je vous le dis franchement voilà vous
connaissaient ses antécédents pour dire
ça
brabham était fait
[Applaudissements]
c ette ces dons c'est que tu l'as vu sa
tête saad uts energy croche pas pourquoi
ça m'a énervé près j'avais commandé des
pizzas pas bien sûr j'étais au top
j'étais que faire je les regarde un
match on était contents et mon fils de
10 ans m'a dit papa c'est pas normal que
des gens comme ça rentre dans le stade
et la dizaine au sénat là il à la fac
ça qui parle comme ça clame mais c'est
vrai vous le défendez
m maître gims mais
s'il verse connaissent un amoureux du
football on est no l'eau sale amoureux
de football chan amoureux de football ça
nous a gâché nos dimanches à l'origine
est une bouteille faut peut-être en
faire un exemple c'est pas possible on
va avec nos enfants au stade voir penser
que cette sanction va va faire que doute
vous dira non il a eu une exemption à
exactement voilà carradine est ce que
vous pensez que ça va ça va arrêter les
ahlaouis parce qu'en fait c'est pas fini
d'abord il a été jugé en comparution
immédiate ces procédures extrêmement
rapide il a été interpellé dans le stade
il n'est pas ressorti du stade et des
services de police jusqu'à sa
comparution devant le tribunal il a
entendu les réquisitions six mois ferme
pour quelqu'un qui n'avait quasiment
jamais été condamné c'est durant
ils avaient jeté du pull cossu ringarde
classe
y avait une mention très ancienne oui
capable clé dans le débat et qui avait
rien à voir c'était une affaire
d'escroquerie cacapa à lattes mois vers
veridian n'avoir rien à voir avec les
faits autrement dit c'est un homme à
céret à père de famille n'avait
justement
laissez moi finir avec
avant de dire qu'un homme doit aller en
prison la moindre des choses ouvrez le
dossier mais vous avez déjà été condamné
pour escroquerie il faut voir les
antécédents il avoue voir les choses
c'est de ne pas dire qu'il est père de
famille parce qu'il donne un exemple
derrière chose malaisie mais c'est pas
fini presstalis est pas fini j'ai eu la
piqûre est qu'ils se constituent partie
civile bien sûr il nous demandait aucun
pour l'instant dommages intérêts ils ont
réservé leurs droits ça va tomber un oui
il m'a peut-être un mal tomber et après
ça pose la question de la gestion de la
crise et ce qu'il fallait oui ou non
arrêté le match c'est ça la question
ouais parce que les spectateurs ils sont
restés deux heures dans le stade vous
rendez vous rendez compte six doigts qui
doit payer vos unités là pour rembourser
tout le monde et 57 mille spectateurs 70
euros la place en moyenne à aimer pizza
eh bien
on va le faire l'union bâle 5 millions
d'euros oui ça représente mais il peut
payer ses charges et cristalline